- Il est 14 heures, premier jour
du mois de septembre. Mais avec
chaque jour qui passe, la notion
du temps s'évapore. L'attente
ici est interminable, surtout
pour eux; les enfants. Ils n'ont
plus aucun repère, que des
clôtures partout qui limitent
leurs déplacements. Mais ils ont
tout suivi connu pire.
- Hadia et ses parents étaient
en visite en Afghanistan pour
le mariage de son oncle quand
les talibans ont soudainement
repris la capitale. Elle nous
raconte son périple vers
l'aéroport de Kaboul avec
ses proches.
- À huit ans, c'est elle qui
sert d'interprète pour les
membres de sa famille qui
l'entourent, que les Américains
ont évacué et présente charge
à titre de réfugiés.
- Elle plaide à qui veut bien
l'entendre : il faut absolument
aller chercher tous ceux qui
sont restés là-bas. Ces images
et témoignages que nous avons pu
filmer ne sont qu'un petit
échantillon de l'angoisse qui
habite toute la base militaire
de Rammstein, en Allemagne.
Un point de transfert crucial
qui s'est transformé du jour
au lendemain en camp de fortune.
- La commandante Adrienne
Williams n'a jamais rien vu tel
en 35 ans de carrière militaire.
22 000 évacués en moins de 10
jours déjà qui arrivent souvent
sans papiers, exténués ou
malades.
Ses enfants qu'on voit circuler
avec leur famille, ça y est,
ils ont reçu le feu vert pour
quitter la base. Ils vont monter
à bord d'avion et s'envoler pour
les États-Unis. Le problème
demeure que pour chaque avion
qui décolle, il y a un autre
qui arrive avec des centaines
d'autres réfugiés. Beaucoup
dorment dans des tentes souvent
à même le sol, car il manque
des lits et même de nourriture.
- Ça fait presque une semaine
que notre équipe communique
avec nosta Kohistani qui attend
désespérément que le Canada
vienne le chercher, lui et 14
membres de membres de sa famille
immédiate. Il n'est pas loin, à
quelque centaines de mètres de
nous, mais impossible de visiter
la section où ils sont logés sur
la base militaire. Il était un
interprète pour l'armée
canadienne, mais c'est celle des
États-Unis qui les a rescapés
avec cette garantie sur papier
qu'ils sont considérés citoyens
canadiens.
- Sans nouvelles ni aide
consulaire du Canada, ils se
demandent s'ils n'ont pas été
oubliés dans ce cauchemar
logistique qui est la plus
grande évacuation rien de
l'histoire américaine, où est
Ottawa? dit-il. Le Canada promis
d'accueillir des dizaines de
milliers de réfugiés afghans
dont 5000 d'urgence pour
désengorger les bases
américaines comme celle où nous
sommes. Mais pas un seule avion
canadienne a été vissée sur le
tarmac.
- C'est le destin de milliers
d'Afghans qui est en jeu devant
les connu, c'est souvent
l'espoir qui prend le dessus.
Ils sont en vie, même si
beaucoup ignorent où et quand
ils pourront la rebâtir.
Ici Tamara Alteresco.
Radio-Canada, Rammstein.